i know you're all bunched up in inside
your home right now because that shit's
going on
yeah i have a dock for your old ass
think making the murderer marry you we
love making you like
part two sucked think of an original
making a murderer then
anna hernandez documentary then they
love them right yeah now imagine those
two had a baby
and then out came this documentary
called outcry
five part series outcry dude new
new next stop showtime showtime sound
like a homer
it's okay showtime five-part series
right my brian daly my boy at showtime
texas
hey not sure if you watch uh outcry it's
right up your alley and i was like oh
yeah would it you know all right what is
it
he tells me like all right last night
nothing to watch it's about nine o'clock
sucked in and i was like i need
something [ __ ] it i'll check it out
click on it
dude i don't know what's it about dude
don't tell manny just tell me what it's
about let me tell you what it's about
kid named greg kelly right outside
austin texas
stud football player handsome dude sure
super stud
got a division one scholarship had three
offers from rice
uh texas san antonio decides to go to
utsa university of texas san antonio
gets a full ride
he's the star football player stutter
the town their
big 5a school so he's a [ __ ] stud
right
his position i think he was a safety
or but either way white guy right white
and
latin mix his family his mom
for some reason they have to leave the
district and go move over here
and but he's in his senior year and he
goes well i i got finished you know
i had my senior year coming up i got to
play so a booster who's a big
lady booster lady for the football team
goes he can stay with me
he'll stay with me the mom goes oh my
god that's so nice of you
yeah no problem family moves he stays
there for a senior year
she did so good dude she runs a daycare
there
right it's the summer and next thing you
know the kid gets a call
from uh the texas police i think austin
police and goes
uh you've been accused of sexual assault
against a four-year-old boy
jesus who's been staying there he goes
excuse me jesus christ
a four-year-old boy they show the video
of this four-year-old being interrogated
by the detectives
and as a as a father you watch this i i
have a four-year-old right now
there's no way the kid would make this
up the kid goes yeah
greg asked me to uh if he could put his
pee pee in my mouth
and you're watching you're pissed and
i'm sick to myself i'm like oh [ __ ] this
dude are you kidding me it's
unbelievable
so uh under texas law they call it super
aggravated sexual assault against a
minor the least you can give law
the least it's already a good law it's a
great it sounds great it sounds like a
cool car
the least you could get is 20 car
25 years with no parole that's the
minimum well you got to get them off the
street you can have people like that
right i agree with it the maximum is 99
years no parole okay so 25 to 99
then he's like what so they book them
they take them in
a week later another kid comes out
another kid comes out
he's like what the [ __ ] so before they
they were going to go to
trial the prosecution goes hey
you can plea and you get five years
parole
no prison no fire's parole but you're
convicted sexual
uh predator you're a lifesaver and the
kid goes i i'm innocent no i'm not
taking that deal
i'm not taking a deal let's go to court
i'm innocent they go to court
they find him guilty of both accounts
they found him guilty and you're like
what the [ __ ] now don't tell me anymore
dude told me a little too much dude now
hold on wait teeth
i mean so it's now dude i'm telling you
dude it's a five part series
and i started on episode one i was like
oh my i look up my girl
we don't say a word for the i think
they're just 60 minutes long we don't
say a single word riveting
oh dude it's unbelievable
what happens to this kid well you
watched the whole thing
no problem i was up to 2 a.m you can't
stop
my detective shop was on the cake yeah
you got to figure it out i figured out
by episode 3 what's going on really
interesting kid's name's greg kelly okay
it's
but i've been as a father yeah i mean
the kids because one could get
well the kids did get actually molested
yeah all right so don't no more
no more no more no spoilers i'm now i'm
in
are you how can you watch that tonight
i'll tell you
tonight i'm gonna tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected